the Liberals of course prefer to dwell
on shootings uh that occur every weekend
in places like Chicago or Oakland or
Baltimore no of course they don't well
places with tough gun laws have huge
crime problems in the United States but
of course if there's a horrible shooting
committed by a crazy lunatic in small
town America as we have now they're
going to jump on the opportunity to try
to take guns out of the hands of
law-abiding citizens we must continue to
speak truth about about the moment we
are in gun
violence has terrorized and
traumatized so many of our communities
in this country and let us be clear it
does not have to be this way as our
friends in Australia have
demonstrated now let's take a look at
what Australia has actually done in 1996
the country launched a huge Crackdown on
gun ownership outlawing automatic and
semi-automatic rifles and shotguns they
also launched a mandatory Nationwide gun
buyback more than 640,000 guns were
destroyed that year in order to own a
gun in Australia you need to have a
quote genuine reason for having one and
to go even further they are right now
trying to create a national gun registry
joining me now is Coy anoir Second
Amendment Advocate and attorney collean
um is kamla signaling gun grab as their
dream is a gun grab in the United States
is that not true no that's absolutely
true um she was even asked one time
during an interview if she believed in a
mandatory buyback which is basically
euphemism for a confiscation and she
basically said yes that's exactly what I
want to do but they like to use these
euphemisms to fool a lot of people in
the masses so they don't realize that a
gun buyback a mandatory gun buyback is
literally a gun confiscation which is
exactly what they did in Australia they
called it a buyback but it was mandatory
which is a
confiscation so it's just the semantic
game that they're playing what was what
was interesting collean today and
looking um through the coverage of what
was happening this horrific uh these
horrific killings in in Maine is
individuals who were barricaded in their
homes would come out and talk to uh
police and come out and talk to media
and so many of them were saying you know
thank thank you for being here to the
police I wish I owned a firearm I saw
that three or four times today and I
think when people are feel vulnerable
they wish they could defend
themselves yeah see the irony is is
Maine is considered what the second most
safest state in the country and they
also are considered one of the most
proun states in the country the the the
thing is though when you live in a very
safe environment sometimes we get lolled
into complacency and we think that we're
safe because because we feel safe which
doesn't necessarily mean you are safe
and then when you start to realize that
you know maybe I should have a firearm
it usually happens when it's too late
and so that's why you have individuals
now saying well now there's a Manhunt
going on and the police don't know where
he is and now you're at home you don't
have a firearm you have no means to
protect yourself and neither can the
police because they're too busy looking
for the guy so that's the one thing that
I've always tried to hamper on people
with respect to the Second Amendment
it's there to give you the ability to
protect you and your family and I just
wish that people would understand that
but because of the semantics and the
games that the left likes to play with
respect to the Second Amendment they
they fall into this belief system that
nobody needs a firearm until you do and
then at that point it's too late yeah or
you have to just you you have to go to
the government to justify you're
exercising your inalienable rights which
is not the way the founders understood
it col and thank you so much